um so you're running for you're running
right now you're running for president
yeah with the Democratic under the
Democratic party right at the moment
okay and so the is it usual is it normal
that someone is able to run against the
incumbent just I want to make this clear
from audience because some audience I
hear words a lot of times and I don't
know what they mean right so like the
incumbent is the guy who's already in
office right yeah so if a president has
already done one term then he's the
incumbent as he goes up to do the second
term right yeah and he has to run
against someone who's submitted by the
other party well well he he ultimately
has around about the other party you
know is going to nominate somebody to
run against them so the Republicans will
nominate somebody to run again but if
you're a Democrat
if you're popular within your own party
a lot of times you won't have a
challenger from when within your own
parties so you only have to go to the
prize fight you don't have to
you know fight all the belugas who are
coming after you but and who determines
if they have to fight all the balloons
it would be you know me I I like I would
run against my father ran against Linda
Johnson when you know Linda John in 68.
Lyndon Johnson was an incumbent
Democratic president and my father
challenged him and and ultimately
um Johnson withdrew
uh and
he pulled out of the way it raised and
then my father won the primaries I mean
he was killed my father was killed on
the night at the last night of the
primaries so June 6th
um he won you know the last primaries
California South Dakota and a couple of
others and he was killed that night
my uncle Ted Kennedy ran in 1980 against
Jimmy Carter who was a president of his
own party
um so yeah it's not uncommon for for
people to run against uh president their
own party and you know I uh I've had a
long friendship with Biden
I've known President Biden for at least
40 years oh wow and uh and you know he
has a statue a bus my father on the
behind him in the Oval Office any
picture that you haven't Biden there's a
bus to my father you can call one up
now
um and there's five members of my family
who are working in the administration in
the Biden Administration yeah wow
different you know different ways yeah
yeah and so uh do you think he'll get
the nomination from his party for the
well I think I could beat him in the uh
and yeah that you can see in that middle
one the second one from the right up
there that one there's a there's a life
out there behind him wow that's awesome
that's so cool man that would be cool if
I were my dad
yeah it's wonderful
um do you think that he will get the
yeah so I guess I have two questions
because I think I can beat them if they
give me a fair fight right bro okay but
before that do you think that they'll
he'll get the nomination well I I think
I could get the nomination okay if they
gave me a fair fight I see do you think
that you're currently getting a fair
fight no why well because they're
they're doing you know the Democratic
party is supposed to be neutral they're
not supposed to choose favorites but
they actually endorse them a week after
he declared
and his campaign is being run out of the
democratic party office which seems like
convoluted huh well it's not it's a
conflict and you know because the party
should be separate from the president
even if they're of the same yeah they're
supposed to be even if they're both
democratic yeah the party should be
neutral and say look we're going to be
the referees in this fight it's like
okay it's like if you went to a football
game and the referee in the game was
wearing the same uniform as your the
guys you were playing against right you
say hey hey yeah yeah so that's what
they're doing and what they've done is
they've taken the states
that voted most strongly against Biden
last time around and they've said if
anybody visits those if I visit those
States and no vote in that state will
count in the election
so if I go to New Hampshire which I did
any vote that I get in New Hampshire
will not count and if you get to what
for me so if I beat Biden New Hampshire
and I win all the delegates those
delegates will not be allowed into the
convention but how can they just say
that isn't there like a democratic
process that that overrides that you
would think but actually it the party
makes its own rules and there was a you
know Bernie Sanders they did the same
thing to Bernie Sanders
and he sued them
and said you know you guys were fit
rigged the game against me you fixed it
and the court said yes they did fix it
but actually it's a private club and
they're allowed to fix it it can make up
any rules they want they can do anything
they want so
see this just leans so much more into
like this stuff that like people feel
like their vote doesn't matter there you
go cork can see DNC had the right to rig
primaries against Sanders and that
and that's Debbie Wasserman Schultz who
you know who cared Debbie Wasserman
Schultz for violating the DNC chart
about rigging the Democratic
presidential primaries for Hillary
Clinton against Bernie Sanders and she's
the one who tried to silence me when I
testified before Congress a couple of
weeks ago wow
so anyway it feels like so it feels so
dirty at every turn yeah I mean it's bad
to me it's bad for the country right now
because
so many people think the whole system is
rigged yeah that's what it feels like
man and um if my vote doesn't matter and
we should be I think we should the both
parties should be conducting elections
that are incredibly fair and everybody
looks something that says okay this is a
model the America's the exemplary
democracy for the world should be and
one thing you can say about America is
it has Fair elections and every vote is
counted and you know yeah it's starting
to remind me the articles I would read
in the papers of like Venezuela a lot of
the Central American countries where
they would be
um there would be coups and stuff and
they would be overriding the process
because they thought the elections
weren't fair you know or you know this
will be in the Soviet Union
the Communist party they said we're a
democracy but the party would pick the
candidate and not be the only guy you
could vote for and that is exactly what
they're doing here they're saying
they're you know they're good they're
saying the good and the Badness we have
a democracy but there's only one guy and
everybody's got a vote for him but do
they have the right to do that because
he's the incumbent I understand you have
the right to do it within the Democratic
party process but how do so what is your
path in to really get to the
presidential nomination for 2024 is
there a path for you do you feel like
well if President Biden steps out but
you know the decision kind of has to be
made by October 15th because they're
that soon yeah because you'll know
before Halloween yeah the uh October
15th
um you have to start
uh qualifying in certain States so that
you have you have to declare whether
you're a Democrat or an independent or
republican yeah
and you can't a lot of people think well
you can run as a Democrat and then if
you lose everything then you can just
switch to independent and run on
Independent but you can't do that
because a lot of states have to sore
loser laws and make it so that you have
to choose early and you can't go you
can't come in you know once you've
chosen Democrat you can't switch
independent that's fair because every
year they let Odell Beckham Jr join
another team right before the Super Bowl
and I feel like it's the same fair to
anybody just I get that he's good but it
doesn't seem that fair
um so when do you have to so but you've
already chosen that you're a Democrat
right I mean you've been a lifelong
Democrat is there a chance that you
would run as an independent do you look
at that ever like and how do you even
evaluate that yeah I mean I I you know
if they really shut down the process
we're right now you know we're grappling
with the DNC
trying to get them to do the right thing
but if they rig the process so that I
can't possibly win which is how it's
rigged right now
then I would have to look at other
options I would have to look at running
as you know maybe outside of the party
or something I don't know exactly what I
do I'm hoping that they'll open up the
process and let me run
um you know we pulled this week and I if
if I if President Biden steps down
um I I have a pretty clear path to the
nomination my numbers are better than
any other Democrats including the vice
president Kamala Harris
um so and then uh if he stays in and
they give me a you know a fair fight I
think I can beat him yeah
um so wow so it's kind of it's tough to
figure out kind of you're kind of just
navigating the space huh who's ahead in
the National polls well he beats me
among Democrats in the National polls
but if you could get a third of people
to switch that were Republicans
those polls aren't looking at the
Republicans who want to vote for me or
the independence
okay
um if you can't get it run this year
would you run in the next next one no
I'm are you thinking that far ahead okay
you're not no I'm not thinking all about
that okay
some people say that you are that the
Republican party like set you up to take
do you ever hear Do you hear about this
yeah I hear that and I'm like a stalking
horse for Trump and all I can say is you
know I don't believe that I'm just
asking you I don't believe it well you
should ask me
I mean you shouldn't do it publicly like
you just did but really no no I'm just
kidding okay now you should ask me yeah
yeah but here's the thing here's the
problem with that first of all
if the Democrats make rules that say I
cannot win you know and then they
complain about me running somewhere else
it's like it's like the
you know it's like a guy who murders his
parents and then throws himself on the
mercy of the court because he's an
orphan yeah you know they're they're
they're they're trying to get public
sympathy for a problem that they created
I hate when I see Bananas Foster on the
menu
but no I see what you're saying it's
almost like they're playing two cards
that are trying to do two different
things but one of them kind of concedes
that there's some truth in the other one
yeah but and then the other thing is
that I take more votes from president
Trump than I do from President Biden
right so why would that help them yeah
it's not helping them yeah